the u.s and south korean militaries have
together launched eight ballistic
missiles into the sea on monday a
response to north korean launches a day
earlier it's the second time in recent
months that the u.s and its allies south
korea have jointly responded to similar
moves from north korea many see it as
representing a hardening of seoul's
approach to pyongyang
a fiery early morning display that took
all of ten minutes
its effects were meant to extend well
into the future
the launches of seven south korean
missiles and one american missile in a
live fire exercise
a tit-for-tat reply to north korea's
launching of eight missiles a day
earlier
[Music]
the response came as south korea and its
hawkish new president marked memorial
day commemorations
yoon sukul saying more than ever global
powers must work to contain north korea
north korea's nuclear and missile
threats are getting sophisticated it
fired various ballistic missiles
yesterday
its programs are reaching the level that
threaten not only the peace of the
korean peninsula but also northeast asia
and the world
the world has almost grown accustomed to
seeing this type of weapons
demonstration from north korea
indeed in 2022 alone north korea has
launched 18 rounds of missile tests
including intercontinental ballistic
missiles
military intelligence suggests president
kim jong-un is pushing for north korea's
first nuclear test in nearly five years
north korea has repeatedly launched
ballistic missiles including new icbms
at a high frequency since the beginning
of this year
a series of north korean actions
threaten the peace and stability of the
region and the international community
they cannot be tolerated
the north's previous launches were last
month as u.s president joe biden wrapped
up a trip to south korea and japan
when biden reaffirmed the u.s commitment
to defending both allies
and kim reaffirmed his desire for north
korea to become a nuclear power
and joining me now for more from seoul
is reuters senior correspondent josh
smith josh joint u.s and south korean
missile launchers in response to north
korea does this somehow symbolize the
new south korean policy towards its
northern neighbor
it is certainly a return uh in some ways
to uh a new old policy uh one that we
last uh saw in significant uh levels
back in 2017 during the days of uh the
fire and fury threats between kim
jong-un and former u.s president uh
donald trump um this is not the first
time they've done these joint drills uh
this year they also rolled out joint uh
missile drills uh late last month uh
when north korea tested an icbm the day
after u.s president joe biden left the
region
after his first talks in the region but
as you mentioned uh south korean
president yun sukyol has promised to
make this more of a regular occurrence
in response to to north korean missile
launches and given that north korea
appears uh intent on
increasing uh the number of missiles
that it tests i think it's a fair bet to
say that we'll see more of these from
the united states and south korea as
well
talk to us a bit about those north
korean missile launches should they be
viewed as missile tests or a sign of
diplomacy north korea style
so there are uh certainly multiple
reasons why north korea would test
missiles including domestic messaging as
well as basically uh you know just
developing the military technology that
it wants uh at the same time there is
undeniably a geopolitical message beyond
that uh the timing of these latest
missiles for example came right after uh
south korea and the united states held
the first joint naval drill involving an
american aircraft carrier uh in a number
of years and so it's hard to see that as
entirely a coincidence
at the same time north korea has been
battling uh what it says is its first
cobit outbreak and something that's
interesting that's happened during that
time is that they've stopped publicizing
or releasing any photos of their missile
tests so we're basically solely
dependent on what countries like south
korea and japan report
so unlike some of their other tests
earlier this year these latest tests
we don't know a lot of details we don't
know exactly what they fired um although
they do appear to be short-range
missiles uh so not its biggest missiles
which some analysts say would suggest
perhaps a military drill practicing uh
rather than developing uh some kind of
new technology
i did want to talk to you about north
korea's covert outbreak i mean given
that they've announced they've admitted
that they have an outbreak it also
appears to be that they don't have
enough vaccinations or any vaccinations
for that matter or enough medical
supplies to cope with this yet we are
seeing these missile launches i mean
what does that say about the country's
priorities
uh that is a big question and one that
for example uh you know
washington has uh not been hesitant to
point out um saying that you know if if
sanctions were really causing so many
problems why do they have the resources
to conduct these tests at the same time
i mean north korea has said that
these tests are its uh self-defense and
basically a a matter of life and death
for the country itself um and that's the
case that they've made to domestic
audiences before at the same time you
know as mentioned they haven't been
publicizing this including to folks at
home and uh analysts have said that may
point to them being a bit worried about
the imagery of them uh continuing to
shoot these off while not having the
resources necessarily to battle the
covet outbreak
and in the midst of all this there are
also reports that the north is preparing
for its first nuclear test since
september 2017 what are you hearing in
seoul
so the the last we heard uh was late
last month from south korean officials
who uh
went beyond kind of what we'd seen in in
satellite imagery of them preparing some
of the underground tunnels that they
previously used for the tests um to say
that they had actually um uh that north
korea had actually begun testing
components of a nuclear weapon
detonators and other things
which suggested that it was basically uh
any day now that we might see a new test
basically what officials here and
analysts have said is that
by all accounts and from everything that
they can tell all of the technical um
progress has been made toward resuming
tests it basically all just comes down
to when kim jong-un decides
to conduct a new test or not
we'll leave it there for the time being
thank you so much for joining us from
seoul josh smith